pocos días después del primer terremoto
kamala bujazán y su familia volvieron a
lo que quedó de su casa
el lunes cuando se produjo el segundo
movimiento telúrico salieron corriendo
mientras parte de su vivienda se
derrumbaba
este terremoto ha acabado con nuestros
medios de vida qué podemos hacer solo
queremos que los niños estén a salvo
nuestra casa está en ruinas Pero al
menos nuestros hijos están bien ahora
viven en una tienda de campaña fuera de
la casa demasiado asustados para volver
a entrar y lo mismo le ocurre a los
habitantes de toda la región
la sensación de miedo es indescriptible
las mujeres tenían miedo los niños ya no
pueden dormir dentro y la mayoría de las
familias están en la calle
el primer terremoto El 6 de febrero
afectó acerca de 9 millones de personas
en Siria causando millones de muertos y
heridos fue tan fuerte que según las
autoridades las réplicas seguirán
sintiéndose Durante un año los
habitantes del enclave Rebelde del Norte
del país ya estaban pasando apuros y
muchos vivían en campamentos y dependían
de la ayuda humanitaria una de Naciones
Unidas visitó la región el martes para
evaluar los daños y las necesidades de
Los afectados la población local ha
criticado el tiempo que ha tardado en
llegar la ayuda dada la reticencia del
gobierno sirio autorizar las entregas
desde Turquía a las zonas en poder de
los Rebeldes la ONU llegó a un acuerdo
la semana pasada para abrir más pasos
fronterizos pero los críticos afirman
que la grave situación exigía una
respuesta más rápida